we used to plant our our crops by the
start of the year and we didn't get
anything at all from our farms because
we didn't have enough for info so it is
a size one that is a the best crop that
can withstand the drought
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to my workshop i'm called alexa
mundo and am an innovator or simple
Agricole machines
according to the UN Africa is one of the
most vulnerable continents to climate
change due to its poverty levels scarce
water sources and rain-fed farmland
farmers here in Kenya are being forced
to look for new more drought resistant
options to grow when traditional crops
fail this is where sisal comes in sisal
is built for harsh climates under its
green exterior are strong fibers that
are useful in making all sorts of things
there's just one problem
you can see the initial stages is very
labor-intensive so this takes a long
time because my mother used to do this
and she could only get little fiber
throughout the day she was selling the
product to buy us some schoolbooks
uniforms buy us food as a young boy I
liked I liked science I promised my
mother but one day I'll give you a
machine that is going to help you
process much more fiber building that
machine took a long time in that journey
I can remember eight prototypes and the
ninth one is the one that that that
worked this is the say salty kata-kata
this was Alex's first invention it
constricts size of fibers in seconds
these fibers can be sold for 20
shillings per kilo
but this wasn't enough for Alex this is
the sesor tweener
this machine turns the fibers into rope
which adds value of almost 180 percent
the Rope can be used to make a variety
of items like bags and mats the sofa
absorb a too tall it's modern and a
hundred machines when they buy machine
from me
I ain't unhide them to plant more sisal
at least one acre so that if they fail
to get these other crops then they are
able to get their finances from the
sisal plant
I cannot give them handout every day but
if I seek them something that is going
to help them in their entire life then I
think that's very important for me and
that's why I think sisal is one of the
thing that I can take to them and if
they buy the idea and I believe their
life you know depend mean the same again
[Music]
you